en este vídeo vamos a ver otro ejemplo
de como graficar funciones racionales
vamos a tomar ye igual a 2 x 2 x
dividido entre x + 1 vamos a empezar
identificando las así notas horizontales
como te comentaba para hacer eso tenemos
que ver los términos de mayor grado en
el numerador y en el denominador bueno
en el numerador únicamente tenemos un
término que es 2x así que ese es el de
mayor grado pero en el denominador
tenemos a x y a 1 x es el término de
mayor grado entonces qué sucede conforme
x tiende a infinito
qué pasa si x x tiende a infinito si x
se hace muy muy grande positivo bueno 2
x es básicamente 2x entonces ya se
parece a 2x dividido entre pero aquí en
el denominador pues este 1 ya no va a
importar porque porque x es muy muy
grande entonces este uno es
insignificante
de modo que el denominador se parece a x
y así que se parece a 12 x / x que es lo
mismo que 2 de esta forma cuando x se
hace muy muy muy grande que tiende a 2 y
lo mismo sucede si ponemos menos
infinito o sea si aquí se va a infinito
o al menos infinito pues también podemos
usar el mismo argumento este uno es
insignificante que se parece a 2 x / x
que es lo mismo que 2 vale entonces
tenemos una a sin tota horizontal en g
igualados déjame dibujarla aquí en la
gráfica nos quedaría una línea
horizontal
a esta altura aquí está estoy dibujando
en color verde y punteada vale está
punteada porque es nada más la acin
total le voy a poner así en total al
quinto está horizontal
horizontal vale entonces como
platicábamos esta idea de la asín total
quiere decir que la gráfica de la
función cuando x es muy grande se va a
acercar a esta línea pero nunca la va a
tocar vale entonces dependiendo si x es
muy grande positivo o negativo pues nos
estamos acercando por acá o por acá
bueno antes de dibujar la gráfica vamos
a pensar en el siguiente paso vamos a
pensar si haya sin notas verticales para
eso necesitamos que el denominador se
anule y puede ser que x + 1 sea igual a
0 pues si resulta que esta función está
indefinida cuando x es igual a menos 1
porque ahí el denominador se hace 0 y
tendríamos una división entre 0 déjame
apuntarlo voy a ponerle indefinido
indefinida definida
x igual a menos 1 si x es menos uno x
uno es cero y estamos dividiendo entre
cero y justo eso es lo que hace que se
creen asientos verticales bueno hay que
tener un poco más de cuidado hay que ver
que este término no se cancela con nada
de arriba es más déjame darte un ejemplo
voy a pasar de este lado de cuando si se
cancelan
imagínate que tenemos ye igual a x1
dividido entre x más 1
qué sucede aquí en x igual a menos 1
pues una vez más tenemos que esta
función está indefinida porque aquí
abajo tendríamos menos 1 1 que sería 0
arriba también tendríamos 000 entre 0
sigue siendo una cosa indefinida no
sabemos cuánto es 0 entre 0 vale
entonces x bueno x tiene que ser aquí
tiene que ser distinto de menos 1 en
menos uno está indefinida
ahora si x es distinto de menos 1
entonces ahora si estas dos cosas son
iguales y no son 0 y podemos cancelar
las de modo que podemos pensar a estar a
esta función a esta expresión racional
como y igual a 1 vale cualquier cosa
entre sí misma es igual a 1 siempre y
cuando no sea 0 entonces cómo quedaría
la gráfica pues mira aquí puse otros
ejes para graficar la entonces
básicamente sería la gráfica de la
función igual a 1 es decir sería una
línea horizontal a la altura igual a 1
excepto cuando x es igual a menos 1
entonces cuando x es igual a menos 1 es
como por aquí
entonces tendríamos esta línea déjame
pintarla con otro color con este verde
entonces tenemos una línea horizontal
que viene por acá no hay problema no hay
problema llegamos a -1 y aquí tenemos
poner un circulito hueco para indicar
que la función ahí está indefinida donde
seguimos por acá seguimos por acá y
entonces ésta sería la gráfica de esta
expresión racional o de esta función
vale ahí tenemos que poner un pequeño
hueco bueno déjame pasar aquí arriba
para regresar al problema original mira
nada más déjame decirte otra cosa aquí
no hubo asín total verdad aquí no pasó
que la función se acercara a la línea
vertical y justo esto sucedió porque se
canceló el x + 1 entonces regresando
regresando al ejemplo aquí sí vamos a
tener una asiento está vertical porque
este x + 1 no se cancela con nada
entonces abajo si se cancela no haya sin
total aquí no se cancela entonces si
vamos a tener un asiento está vertical
en x igual a menos 1 déjame pintarla con
el mismo color naranja de aquí abajo
entonces cuando x es igual a menos 1
ahora tenemos una línea punteada por
aquí vale entonces en esa línea no vamos
a tener ningún punto de la gráfica de la
función porque ahí la función ya
igualados x entre x + 1 está indefinida
bueno entonces ya tenemos nuestras 2 a 5
estás ya nada más déjame probar algunos
valores para ver pues algunos puntos que
están sobre la gráfica ya para entender
bien bien qué sucede con todo déjame ver
qué sucede cuando le ponemos x igual a
cero entonces por ahí en la gráfica
tenemos el punto cero coma y hay que ver
qué nos queda aquí nos queda dos por
cero es cero búsqueda cero dividido
entre 0 1 nos queda 0 / 10 / cualquier
cosa que no sea 0 es 0 entonces el punto
0 0 está en la gráfica de la función lo
pinto por aquí vale entonces ahí está
vamos a poner otro valor digamos x igual
a 1 para ver qué pasan por acá entonces
sí pongo x igual a 1 me queda 2 x 1 o
sea 2 dividido entre uno más uno o sea
entre 2 2 entre 2 es igual a 1 entonces
también tenemos el punto 1 coma
entonces este punto de acá también está
y esos dos puntos claro o sea podríamos
poner más pero tan solo con esos dos
puntos y con las cintas que ya tenemos
podemos tener una muy buena idea de cómo
se ve la gráfica de la función
básicamente va a venir desde acá desde
menos infinito aquí cerquita de la 5ta
va a ir creciendo va a ir creciendo
hasta llegar al punto cero cero entonces
es más o menos algo así y luego aquí
tiene que irse al punto 11 y empezar a
acostarse para ahora acercarse a la 5ta
horizontal a la 5ta horizontal ye igual
a 2 vale entonces tenemos que la gráfica
de la función ahora si hace esto de este
lado vale bueno vamos a ver qué sucede
por acá entonces déjame probar algunos
valores de este lado con otro color para
que no sea tan monótono vamos a probar
los valores menos 2 y menos 3 vale para
ver qué pasa entonces si le pongo x
igual a menos 2 me queda 2 x menos 2 o
sea menos 4
/ / 21 - 21 es menos 1 entonces aquí me
queda 4 entonces sería menos 2,4 tenemos
también el punto menos 2 - 1 - 2,4 1234
este de acá
y finalmente dejar de ponerle x igual a
menos 32 x menos 3 es menos 6 dividido
entre menos 31 menos 31 es menos 2 a
quien es para menos 2 menos 6 entre
menos 2 es igual a tres así que otro
punto en la gráfica es el menos 3,3 lo
voy a poner por acá menos 1 - 2 - 3 1 2
ahí tenemos estos dos puntos y
finalmente tenemos que extrapolar bueno
más o menos dibujar cómo está esto y
bueno como tenemos las cintas otra vez
pues tenemos que para acá se tiene que
acercar a la cinta
entonces empezamos aquí pegaditos a la
cinta está bueno muy cerquita de la
cinta luego empezamos a crecer hasta
llegar al menos 33 tocamos este de acá
el menos 24 y finalmente al acercarnos
al valor x igual a menos 1 tenemos que
irnos a infinito para acercarnos ahora a
esta cinta vale entonces ahí vamos
creciendo y vamos creciendo pero nunca
la tocamos muy bien entonces está
padrísimo ya tenemos más o menos como se
ve la gráfica de la función ya nada más
para comprobar que realmente es así
déjame sacar la calculadora para hacer
la gráfica entonces aquí tenemos la
calculadora déjame encenderla vamos a
graficar y voy a graficar 22 x dividido
entre x x
+ 1 muy bien déjame ver si estos rangos
están bien y le picó graficar mira wow
esto es exactamente lo que nosotros
dibujamos aquí viene la gráfica está
pegada a la cinto está horizontal
empieza a crecer crecer se va a infinito
en la 5ta vertical en x igual a menos 1
luego empieza de menos infinito y creció
otra vez a la asiento está ya que otra
vez aquí tenemos una línea rara que
dibuja la calculadora pero eso es por
como las calculadoras hacen las cosas
hacen una tabla detallada de valores de
la función y luego pues unen los puntos
con líneas entonces aquí también la
dibuja aunque en realidad recuerda la
asín total no es parte de la gráfica de
la función sino nada más es una línea
auxiliar que nos dice cómo se comporta
la gráfica bueno espero que te haya
gustado este vídeo y nos vemos en el
siguiente para ver un ejemplo más